why are you so angry we guess why are
you running an inn when you're so bitter
you look like you don't give a [ __ ] I'm
not saying that I don't like to guess
that that if you have ever been an
innkeeper its 24/7 no one is more
touched by what these people said well
already clearly that's I would love this
to be our our private home but I am lost
and Arie does have a different way of
dealing with I see this based on my
experience I would seriously request
both you actually sit down and
reconsider whether you should be in this
business going forward
[Music]
it's clear to me that re isn't cut out
for the hospitality business and even
though Robert now understands how he's
let down his guests he needs to
understand that he's also let down his
staff and failed to recognize that
potential I've got a plan that will help
Robert to see what he's doing wrong and
how he can fix things in his kitchen
[Music]
I've asked chef Julian to cook three
dishes from Roberts expensive old menu
and three new dishes of his very own
creation once he's finished going to
pretend I cooked the new ones and see
what Robert says crucially Jr's dishes
are all ones that could be served on a
$29 menu half what Robert currently
charges 74 dollars $29 let's go good
luck okay yes I can't wait to see what
Robert thinks of Junior's affordable
food when he thinks I've cooked him I
asked him to cook a three-course meal
yeah he cooked his lamp his crab cake
and the dessert that's the $74 version I
cook the other meal like a hold of some
chicken some sprouts and I used the crab
and butterscotch pudding with some
caramel popcorn $29 that's what those
three courses I got at cost
Junior's three new dishes are fantastic
and fairly priced that would go a long
way towards bringing guests back through
the front door
now the Robert things I've cooked them i
Betty loves them talk to me well
excellent fabulous and the Brussels
sprouts are really good too you've
actually leaves them and it's very
pretty this is a much better value I've
never heard you use that word value and
we could get to price of one
or we should new so my menu or Julian's
menu here menu my menu I'm flattered but
there's something I need to tell you I
didn't make any of this
Julian cook everything I felt at that
very moment that I had done Julian a
disservice Roberts have you got
something you'd like to say to your chef
Julian I'm sorry that I haven't given
you the freedom to do what you need to
do I guess I have to eat it and say that
I have restricted him from being who he
can be which is is really difficult and
I have to say that this is delicious